the fifth episode of Game of Thrones
eighth and final season was many things
tense and cinematic yup full of shots
that looked straight out of an action
movie oh yeah but the penultimate
episode left us with one burning
question we will take the Iron Throne
now spoilers ahead there's no nice way
to describe the most recent episode of
Game of Thrones Daenerys Targaryen had
typed King's Landing and set the city
ablaze and she refused to back down even
after Circe's army surrendered thousands
of innocent people were burned to a
crisp by dragon's fire or slaughtered by
the nurses and solid soldiers and
Dothraki riders it was in a word brutal
until she stormed King's Landing
Daenerys looked poised to become the new
ruler of the Seven Kingdoms because
she's a door to a Varys Targaryen
otherwise known as the Mad King she's
always had a claim to queenship over the
years Daenerys has proven she has what
it takes to rule strength compassion
where accounts and the buyers for
bloodshed were necessary which is also
killed without mercy in the past and she
hasn't always strategized wisely without
the guidance of a council her behavior
and the latest episode threatens to undo
all of her past triumphs many fans are
convinced she took a free fall and she
destroyed King's Landing and there's no
way she'll ever be able to redeem
herself unless she can persuade the rest
of Westeros to bend the knee and
recognize her as queen there's a good
chance she won't fulfill her deepest
desire to sit on the Iron Throne as a
father once did that brings us to Jon
Snow he's a legitimate heir to the Iron
Throne but he's made his feelings on the
matter quite clear I don't want it I
never have he bent the knee to Daenerys
before either of them knew his true
parentage and so far he's remained loyal
to her but perhaps does more at play
here
particularly since Jon had his brother
cousin bran stark informing sister
cousins Arya and Sansa of his heritage
Sansa and told Tyrion Lannister who told
Varys who was subsequently executed Jon
probably didn't know it set off this
chain of events but other people might
think it was all a deliberate ploy some
fans think Jon will be forced to kill
Daenerys thus ending her reign of terror
he'd take the Iron Throne against his
true desires but for the greater good of
his people that would certainly fulfill
the vision Daenerys had back in season 2
in which Dany envisioned herself walking
through the throne room looking up to
see the sea
torn apart then approaching the iron
throne that was covered in snow after
watching this most recent episode many
believe the snow is actually ash
but what if her vision represented Jon
Snow taking the throne if John doesn't
sees he I'm thrown another force on the
north curd Sansa
she's a keen political strategist and
she has no trouble delivering justice
when it's required thank you for all
your many lessons Lord Baelish he'll
never forget them a childhood spent in
King's Landing under the watchful eyes
of Cersei Lannister force her to grow up
quickly turning her into one of the
smartest most compassionate people in a
room though her heart has remained with
Winterfell and the north she began a
game of Thrones wanting to serve as
queen alongside King Joffrey more than
anything
perhaps the part of Varys still holding
on to that dream we last saw Arya riding
on the back of a pale horse badly
wounded and escaping the rubble of
King's Landing maybe she's on a way to
kill Daenerys or maybe she's making her
way back to Winterfell to warn everyone
that Dany has really lost it this time
Arya has exhibited many characteristics
of a strong leader determination cunning
and compassion for others some fans
think Arya will kill Downey and then put
a training at the house of black and
white to good use ruling Westeros using
someone else's face then again if that
would contradict arias previous
statement again Dre I'm not lady
I never have been that's not me consider
Brandt as wild as it sounds he could
genuinely take the Iron Throne he's
technically not even bran stark anymore
he's a three-eyed Raven and he uses his
powerful gifts to keep people well
informed and well prepared tyrion
lanister once told brannad make an
excellent leader and brands seem to
cryptically suggests he had no desire
for the throne they don't really want
anymore a lot of fans are putting their
money on bran because of a remark Varys
made about who should oversee Westeros
have you considered the best rule and
might be someone who doesn't want to
rule to guide them into a brighter
future people will want someone new and
unlike any other ruler they've seen
before and to better to teach future
generations about history than an entity
that can access more information than
anyone else in the world the final major
contender for the Iron Throne is Tyrion
Lannister he's certainly proven capable
in politics and he remains a hand of the
Queen to Daenerys even if he's realizing
that she's in no position to role if
Danny dies in the series finale Tyrion
will arguably be the most politically
savvy character left standing he's
fought in battles he's masterminded war
strategies while advising kings and
queens he's learned that ruling isn't
all about extremes plus he saved King's
Landing before in the Battle of the
Blackwater that means there's a good
chance he can prevent further drama down
the road if he takes the throne when it
comes right down to it there's a
distinct possibility that no one will
sit on the Iron Throne
perhaps the sacred Sikh corrupts anyone
who takes her and the Song of Ice and
Fire was meant to end on a hollow note
and with an empty chair as we've seen
before absolutely anything can happen on
the show for now all we can do is wait
the answer will be revealed when the
final episode of Game of Thrones airs
Godspeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]